special place for me because that's
where I've lived for 37 years and it's
where I served for many years on the
city council and as mayor
that is why I am especially grateful to
President Biden for coming to our city
which has a deep hole in its heart a
hole that is yet to heal to have a
leader of our nation come here to
console our grieving Community is
monumental
President Biden your presence is making
a difference to so many
it was on Lunar New Year's Eve January
21st a time that should have been one of
Celebration and joy that gunman came
into our city at Star Dance Studio
killing 11 people in wounding nine
others he then drove to another dance
studio lilac Ballroom in Alhambra to
shoot even more people
thankfully Brandon's eye heroically
disarmed him
but then he got away
as our entire City and LA area awoke the
next day the fear and shock was palpable
I was on the ground at City Hall back
the next morning I saw the fear in my
neighbor's eyes and heard the terror in
their voice as they told me they were
afraid to go home go shopping or even
send their children to school
a day-long Manhunt ensued but thankfully
Sheriff Robert Luna and his team tracked
him down miles away
surrounded he ended his own life
though the immediate danger of the
shooter was gone Madre Park and the
Asian American Community Nationwide are
still reeling and we are still grieving
as the first suburb in Chinatown in the
U.S montre Park holds a special place in
the heart of a nationwide Asian American
community
that's why it feels as though the attack
on Monterey Park was an attack on Asian
America
I met with the victims families and I've
come to understand how special the
victims were
they were mothers fathers sons and
daughters
they were all Asian American immigrants
from China Hong Kong Vietnam Taiwan and
the Philippines who worked hard to build
their lives here
they did not deserve to be taken from us
but what is making a difference is the
community
I want to thank the community for
helping Saul immensely in their recovery
I know many of you are here today
and I especially want to thank President
Biden for providing every Federal
resource possible
from the moment the shooting happened
federal law enforcement resources were
here on the ground to help in the
Manhunt
then in the days following the attack
vice president Harris and Senior White
House staff were here bringing
condolences from the president
Health and Human Services secretary
Javier Becerra visited here to discuss
our recovery and found that though FEMA
or the Federal Emergency Management
agency coordinates responses in a
natural disaster there is no such
coordinated response after a mass
shooting resulting in much confusion and
frustration
and then
administrator Isabel Busan castillas of
the small business administration
visited the small businesses near the
shooting site to offer resources
we also know this
this Shooter had a semi-automatic pistol
with a high capacity magazine that
allowed him to shoot 42 rounds in a
matter of minutes
he should never have had a weapon that
was made for war
nor should the shooters in Half Moon Bay
Buffalo Uvalde and countless other
places
this Carnage must end
yes
and that's why we must pass a national
assault weapons ban
we also know this shooter was
deteriorating mentally having gone to
the police to complain of his family
poisoning him
our red flag law could have enabled
someone to have his guns removed but I
doubt that our immigrant Community knows
about it
so multilingual Outreach is needed about
this law to all our communities
so President Biden thank you for meeting
with the victims families as well as the
wounded and consoling them
thank you for being with us today in an
ultimate Act of healing
thank you for letting us know that we
are not alone
and thank you for continuing to raise
your voice when assault weapons ban in
this country as well as for measures in
your gun violence executive order
especially with regard to enhanced red
flag implementation and a coordinated
FEMA response to mass shootings
we need it so that no other community
has to go through what we've gone
through thank you
[Applause]
please welcome Los Angeles County
Supervisor Hilda Solis
foreign
I represent the first district on the LA
County Board of Supervisors and I'd like
to start first of all by welcoming
President Biden to Los Angeles County
especially to Monterey Park a city with
over 60 000 residents who I am honored
also to serve and represent
thank you so much for being here the
epicenter of a tragic mass shooting yes
but Mr President this is also an
epicenter of Hope and resilience
here in Los Angeles County I am honored
to have four other colleagues sitting on
a historic all-women board
and by the way are all strong gun safety
Advocates just like myself
just this year alone we have unanimously
passed five gun safety motions including
one you might be familiar with Mr
President you and Senator Feinstein put
forward two bills
to ban military-style weapons and
high-capacity magazines in addition to
raising the age from 18 to 23 years of
age to purchase them and last month
alone I authored a motion that passed
unanimously to support Senator
Feinstein's reissuance of these two
Fields Senate Bill 25 to ban assault
weapons and high-capacity magazines
and Senate bill 14 to raise the age from
18 to 21 to purchase assault weapons
Mr President you are exemplifying what
we need
strong leadership on all levels of
government to be brave to be courageous
and to stand with victims and survivors
against gun violence I refuse to believe
that thoughts and prayers are going to
somehow protect our children
and lift our country out of this gun
crisis your issuance of an executive
order on gun control today is a
example of what is needed precisely here
in America every day we use the
authority we have at the Board of
Supervisors to keep our 10 million
residents safe from gun related violence
and to support the work of other Brave
colleagues that you're going to hear
from and you've already heard from our
congresswoman you'll hear from our U.S
senator
but you'll also hear from our president
and next Tuesday's meeting at the LA
County Board of Supervisors I will be
putting forward a motion to support
President Biden's executive order
Mr President
Mr President you have my support and I
believe the support of many in Los
Angeles County and L.A county is ready
and willing to continue supporting your
efforts and vision to have a safer
America for everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome Senator Alex
good afternoon Monterey Park
good afternoon it is a solemn honor to
be back in Monterey Park today here
alongside so many friends and colleagues
including Representatives Judy Chu and
supervisor Solis whom you just heard
from but also with First Responders
with Community leaders
with friends and loved ones of those
wounded or taken from us in January
and it is my privilege Mr President yes
he can hear me it is my privilege Mr
President to welcome you back to
California
but I must say that this year it's been
too often
in the shadow of tragedy and heartbreak
Today We Gather in Monterey Park
a proud and diverse and welcoming
community
two months ago
it was here that families gathered to
celebrate with good food and Lively
music on the eve of Lunar New Year
and eagerly awaited calls from loved
ones wishing them good fortune in their
new year
but instead
the families of 20 of our neighbors
after a night of horror received a
different type of call
that night as we know a lone gunman
entered the star Ballroom
and claimed 11 lives
while injuring nine others
taken from us
parents and grandparents
and making our aapi community in
particular live in even more fear for
their lives
but there's no denying it we have a gun
violence epidemic in America
the gun industry continues to work
overtime to create a culture of Chaos
because to them American lives are worth
less
than the profits they make are the guns
that they sell
the last year
under President Biden's leadership
Congress broke the Stranglehold of the
good lobby but were passed meaningful
gun safety legislation for the first
time in nearly three decades
[Applause]
but today as We Gather not just to
remember we can celebrate the continued
leadership of President Biden with his
historic executive actions to enforce
background checks to further analyze get
this to further analyze the Despicable
tactic of marketing guns to children
is engaged in but also to make sure that
we search resources for a community like
this in the wake of mass shootings
despite the good that these executive
orders will bring
as we all know there will still be more
work to do
that includes
bringing back Universal background
checks
absolutely
and as supervisor solicious mentions we
should follow the example of then
Senator Biden and our own Senator Diane
Feinstein couldn't work in 1994 in
Banning the sale of assault weapons and
we should ban high capacity magazines as
well
now we don't just remind ourselves of
these proven policies
like
we know the work that we have cut up for
us so we are very clear-eyed and knowing
the opposition that we continue to
encounter from Republican members in
Congress who stand in the way of these
Common Sense gun safety measures
and it'll be easy
as we have in
trauma after tragedy after trauma after
tragedy after so many years
to feel hopeless
but if ever
the United States of America needed to
fight a source of strength it is found
right here in the community of Monterey
Park California
just think about what we saw but the
Nations saw in the days and weeks after
the tragedy in January what we saw was
remarkable resilience
we saw the strength of those who rallied
this community like my guess at this
year's State of the Union addressed the
former mayor Henry Lowe
along with the new mayor the entire
Council all the leaders of this
community elected and otherwise who came
together to pull from home
and healing for so many families
who saw the strength of this very Boys
and Girls Club who honored those lost by
celebrating Lunar New Year
and giving kids a chance at a place to
play
or to cry
and to heal
we saw the strength in the ways of
community members who've gathered to
build a memorial outside the star
Ballroom where neighbors had come
together to comfort one another
and to process the tragedy together
you see as we heal
and it's a process
it's here to take time but as we come
together to heal we know
just as President Biden does
that the pain and the Heartbreak
May diminish over time
but it will never
completely
go away
but we can honor those who were taken
from us
by taking action to prevent future
incidents of gun violence we can and
must save lives we know what to do we
need the will of Republican members of
Congress to help us do it
and we can honor those lost by
reclaiming the sacred spaces and
celebrations and by embracing the people
and places that will always make
Monterey Park strong
and special
thank you all for being here today thank
you for having me
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
Patrick
's
thank you
foreign
okay
[Music]
foreign
thank you
so much
[Music]
there were some stories
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
really nice
thank you
meeting this afternoon
[Music]
thank you
foreign
works
huh
okay
foreign
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the United States
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
please have a seat if you have one
good afternoon
Saturday January 21st 2023.
Lunar New Year
a time to enjoy
a ballroom dance studio
place of Happiness friendship and
belonging
people across backgrounds and
generations celebrating their cultural
roots and bonding
through Ballroom song and dance
place of Refuge where immigrants have
lived for years
supported new immigrants who just
arrived becoming not just friends but
family
but as we all saw
a day of festivity and Light
turned into a day of fear and darkness
holiday of Hope and possibilities marked
by horror and pain
vibrant dances music replaced by vigils
and memorials
11 Souls taken
nine injured
private morning made public
a sense of safety shattered
survivors will always carry the physical
emotional scars
families Left Behind who'll never be the
same one of the worst mass shootings in
California history
tragedy that has pierced the soul of
this nation
here in Monterey Park
the San Gabriel Valley
the heart of the Asian American
community
my dear friend Judy Chu former mayor
of Monterey Park your congresswoman and
chair of congratulations Pacific caucus
Senator Alex Padilla Champion for this
community the entire state
my good friend supervisor Hilda Solis
and all elected officials law
enforcement First Responders Faith
leaders community members all here today
you've shown up for this community
and I know you always will
to the families of victims who spend
time
I get a chance to speak with today and
whom vice president Harris spent time
with a few weeks ago
I'm here on behalf of the American
people
to mourn with you
to pray with you
to let you know you are loved and not
alone
every case is different
but I know what it's like
I notice like to get that call
a notice like to be told a notice like
to lose a loved one so suddenly
it's like losing a piece of your soul
it's like a black hole in your chest I
feel like you're being sucked into
suffocating
hardly able to breathe
the anger the pain
the depths of the law so profound it's
hard to explain
the suddenness
tends to magnify the grief
as time passes the shock and numbness
slowly
make way for the sobering reality of
their absence
an empty chair at the dinner table
birthdays anniversaries
the holidays
without them
everyday things small things the detail
you miss the most the scent when you
open that closet door
the parking your wife that used to
stroll in
the morning team you shared together
the bend of his smile
a perfect pitch of her life
as Judy shared with me
this is a tight-knit community
within our generational households
and deep reverence and respect for its
elders
Community that's opened his heart and
its homes to friends and Neighbors
and so strong throughout the pandemic
as anti-asian hate crimes Rose
community that in the face of horrific
tragedy
has become a symbol of Hope and
resilience
pushing forward together
healing together
people from all facing backgrounds
rallying to show their love and support
raising money for funeral costs and
Memorial providing counseling
and translation services to the victims
families
providing and proving that even with
heavy hearts
we have unbreakable spirits
as a nation
remember them immigrants from China
the Philippines Vietnam
if I want
all who found a home in America
Mr my age 72
pillar of the community
a beloved manager and dance instructor
at Star Ballroom
he walked Patriots with their cars at
night
help new immigrants find jobs
children and grandchildren will carry on
his legacy in the spirit of one of his
favorite Chinese proverbs
cherish the people in front of you
Niguel 72 Mr Nice
for his kindness is positivities
infectious smile
free spirit always ready to lend a
helping hand
he died shielding his dance partner
showed you on you 57.
devoted mom wife sister
woman of faith
always there to help others bringing
food and newspapers to family members
who had trouble walking
always always
working tirelessly with her husband
to build a future for their three
children
62.
known as sister sunshine
she loved to play cards piano
the weekly volleyball game
always sharing her own grown plants and
vegetables and neighbors and Friends
dedicated Mom married nearly 40 years
husband and wife who always together
even in their last dance
Valentino Alvaro
68 years old
servant of God
life of the party
storyteller
who made the whole room laugh
a man devoted to his children and his
grandchildren
may maybe not in 65 Bedrock of her
family and friends
eternal optimist
Avid dancer
who'd visit the studio every weekend
often leaving snacks behind for her
classmates
she radiated positive energy through her
laughter
her kind words
and her smile
more day on 67. Refugee Community
Builder cherish friend known for her
kindness her sweetness her generosity
a beloved family
the center of her world
Diana Tom seven years old devoted
daughter wife mother grandmother
who loved to sing karaoke
a giver and an adventurer who love to
explore new foods and travel the world
Charles Charles 76 grateful reflective
believed in living to the life to the
fullest he constantly showed his family
and friends
and showered them
with warm words of encouragement hope
and love
Tao 64.
a lifelong learner he retired as a
business manager and was pursuing a
second career as a pharmacist
while caring for his Elder mother
elderly mother
a man beloved by his wife children and
Friends
for his compassion
his determination and his wisdom
63.
a matriarch with absolute strength
optimism and Grace
her daughter wrote
stolen as a grandmother whose
granddaughter fell asleep many nights
nestled between her loving arms
taken away is the opportunity for her
grandson
to feel her love and warmth
all the live lives of Love sacrifice
service
for their families for their community
they represent a bigger story
who we are as Americans
embodying the simple truth that our
diversity our diversities the strength
of this nation
we saw that strengthened
Maria Beyond
into creating a warm welcome space
seniors
that strength and Brandon say who met me
at the airport
whom Jill and I have gotten to know
20 minutes after the Rampage
and star Ballroom Brandon saw the same
shooter walk into his family's own Dance
Studio
just two miles away pointing the gun at
him
in an instant he found the courage to
act and wrestle a semi-automatic
firework arm away
Brandon saved lives
he protected the community
and Half Moon Bay just two days later
they've got it
[Applause]
Brandon stand up
Half Moon Bay just two days later we saw
heroism from police officers
firefighters another First Responders
who rushed into the danger to save lives
as many of you know Jill and I invited
Brandon as our guest at the State of the
Union message
because we wanted the country to know
all of you
not just Brandon all of you
the character of this community
the faith you have in this community
The Pride
we see across receipt in you across all
of American Life
just this week a film about resilience
and Power
the Asian American immigrant family made
history at the Oscars
[Applause]
echoing the heart of so many in this
community
we also hear
a message we've heard too often
including two years ago this week
after the spa shooting of the Atlanta
and the Atlanta area enough
do something
we remember and mourn today
but I'm here with you today to act
last year after the mass shooting in
Buffalo New York and Uvalde Texas
I signed into law after being both
places a bipartisan safer communities
Act most significant gun safety law in
almost 30 years
that was in addition to me signing more
executive actions to reduce gun violence
than any of my predecessors at this
point in their presidencies today
I'm announcing another executive order
they'll accelerate and intensify this
work to save more lives more quickly
first this executive order helps keep
Firearms out of dangerous hands
as I continue to call on Congress to
require background checks for all
firearm sales
and in the meantime
[Applause]
in the meantime my executive order
directs my attorney general to take
every lawful action possible possible to
move us as close as we can to Universal
background checks without new
legislation
I just it's just common sense
to check whether someone is a felon a
domestic abuser before they buy a gun
the executive order also expands public
awareness campaigns about the red flag
orders the laws which my son when before
he died attorney general in Delaware was
a great proponent of an Institute
so more parents teachers police officers
Health Providers and counselors know how
to flag for the court that someone is
exhibiting violent tendencies
threatening classmates
who are experiencing Suicidal Thoughts
that make them a danger to themselves
and others and temporarily remove
that person's access to firearms
and it promotes
this executive order safe storage for
firearms something every responsible gun
owner agrees with
second thing it does executive order
ramps up our efforts to hold the gun
industry accountable
it's the only outfit you can't sue these
days
it does that by calling out for an
independent government study
that analyzes and exposes how gun
manufactures aggressively Market
Firearms to civilians especially minors
including by using military imagery
and it directs the Attorney General
the public release publicly released
alcohol tomorrow and fam and Firearms
inspection reports of firearms dealers
who are cited for violation of the law
[Applause]
that way policy makers can strengthen
laws to crack down on those illegal gun
dealers and the public can avoid
purchasing from them
third
the executive order improves Federal
coordination to support victims
survivors and their families and
communities affected by mass shootings
the same way FEMA responds to their
natural disaster in California and all
around the nation
and will help folks recover and build
after a while that they help with folks
recover and build up their wildfires and
Super Storms and droughts for example we
need to provide more mental health
support and grief for grief and Trauma
[Applause]
and more financial assistance in the
family loses the sole Breadwinner or on
a small business shuts down due to
lengthy shooting investigation
there's more in this executive order but
I'm not stopping there
last week I laid out of my budget
that we invest more in safer communities
and expand access to Mental Health
Services for those affected by gun
violence
Congressional Republicans
[Applause]
should pass my budget instead of calling
for cuts in these services or defunding
the police or abolishing the FBI as we
hear from our migrant Republican friends
but let's be clear
none of this absolves Congress the
responsibility
from the responsibility of acting
the past Universal background checks
eliminate gun manufacturers immunity
from liability
and I'm determined once again to ban
assault weapons in high capacity
magazines
I led that fight in
to ban them in 1994.
the 10 years that law was in place mass
shootings went down
a republican friends let it expire
when 10 years later
and mass shootings tripled since then
tripled so let's finish the job ban
assault weapons ban them again do it now
enough do something do something big
[Applause]
folks
let me close with this
scripture says
the Lord is near to a Brokenhearted
and saves the Christian spirit
a lot of us have been there
to gather here today
I know your hearts are broken
they'll know your spirits are strong
and as you remember and heal
I know the light
of your loved one
it's once again going to lead you
forward
it takes time
I tell everyone at least it did with me
but I promise you
I promise you
the day will come
when the memory of your loved one
brings a smile to your lips before it
brings a tear to your eye
cheer will never fully go away
but when you had that smile first
remembrance
that's when you know
that's when you know you're going to
make it
you're going to know you're going to
my prayer for all of you that they will
come sooner than later but I promise you
it will come
God bless you all
I admire you so damn much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
ladies and Gentlemen please remain
seated until the departure of the
official party
[Music]